安心でチュ
楽しいでチュ
(はい、オッケーでーす)
一同：いえーーーい　お疲れでーす
一同：はははｗｗｗｗ
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーと
やぁどうも東海オンエアのてつやと
としみつと
ゆめまると
虫眼鏡だ
はじめ：はい、というわけで皆さんとうでしたか？
はじめ：多分見覚えのあるダンスだと思うんですけども
はじめ：我々で踊ってみました
としみつ：よっ
はじめ：可愛い
てつや：アイドルになれましたよ　念願の
てつや：念願なんだよ　なんだよ
はじめ：いやでも我々ちょっとおじさんなんですけど
はじめ：まぁおじさんなりに可愛く
はじめ：ちょっと本家に近づけるように
はじめ：頑張って踊ってみました
はじめ：はい、で、実はですね
はじめ：なんと！マウスさんと
はじめ：はじめしゃちょーのコラボパソコンができました
東海オンエア：おーーーーー
ゆめまる・としみつ：すごーい
虫眼鏡：すごーーーーい　かっこいい
としみつ：カッコいい
てつや：はじめしゃちょーって書いてある
はじめ：そうです
はじめ：カッコいいパソコンがいいなと思ったんで
はじめ：ちょっと可愛い所沢というかもうゴリゴリの
としみつ：たくましくなってる
はじめ：たくましいｗ
虫眼鏡：男の子でも使えるね
てつや：このロボット感がいいすね
はじめ：ちょっとメカメカしい感じの所沢仕様の
はじめ：パソコンを一緒に作りました
虫眼鏡：個性的〜
はじめ：個性的ｗ
はじめ：でこのパソコンなんですけども
はじめ：なんとスペックも
はじめ：はじめしゃちょーと仕様というか
としみつ：おー
てつや：はじめしゃちょー仕様
はじめ：動画編集よくするんで
はじめ：編集がサクサクできるような
虫眼鏡：すごっ
はじめ：結構な高スペックになっております
虫眼鏡：あー　としみつ：嬉しい
はじめ：そしてもちろんゲームもサクサク動くようになっています
ゆめまる・てつや・としみつ：すごい
虫眼鏡：ノートでそれはすごい
てつや：うん　としみつ：めっちゃすごい
はじめ：はい、というわけでマウスさんのPCは
はじめ：ゲームをサクサクしたとか、開いてすぐ起動してほしいとか
はじめ：自分にぴったりなスペックのパソコンを作って買えちゃうんです
はじめ：はいそしてなんとこちらのはじめしゃちょーコラボパソコンが
はじめ：WEBで販売されまーす
東海オンエア：わあーーー　すごい　おめでとう　欲しい
はじめ：ほんと数量限定になっております
はじめ：えーっと詳しくは動画の概要欄に書いてありますので
はじめ：是非チェックしてみてください
はじめ：ではここから
はじめ：先ほどのダンスのメイキングをご覧いただきます
てつや：なげぇ
はじめ：どうぞおーーー
まめだ：ファイブ　シックス　セブン　エイト
まめだ：ワン　ツー
まめだ：スリー　フォー　ファイブ
まめだ：左足を出した時に左を指します
はじめ：左？なるほど、こうか
まめだ：上体だけ
てつや：ちょっと1回ゆめまるのやつ
虫眼鏡：どこがダサいかをちょっと
はじめ：何が腕がもう
てつや：ビキーンって
一同：ははははｗｗｗ
ゆめまる：ダサくないでしょー
としみつ：なんかあんだろうね
としみつ：ダンスって指先大事なんだよね
てつや：人脈が全て
としみつ：あ…ふざけちゃったから
虫眼鏡：終わった
はじめ：はい、というわけでいかがだったでしょうか
はじめ：ダンスやってみて
はじめ：僕が素直に思ったことは
はじめ：としみつが異常にキレッキレだった
としみつ：あら
てつや：うまい
はじめ：うまいんだよね
としみつ：いや〜＄＆＃％ね
としみつ：えーパソコンもね
としみつ：えー僕にもねおちねーで(？)もらって
としみつ：今日の動画を締めさせていただいて、と思いますね
一同：Fooo
はじめ：みんな俺たちの動画も
はじめ：マウスコンピューターのパソコンで見てくれよな
はじめ：ばいばーい
ゆめまる・てつや・としみつ・虫眼鏡：ばいばーい
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】